it's great to see you here tonight some
of the garlic screening of much ado
course you've worked with Joss Whedon
before what's it like being part of that
world of readers gosh you know what Yas
is just is he's standing right next to
me so I think ever what I say no Joss is
he's an extraordinary man of immense
learning wit and experience and
curiosity he's just is everything I
could hope for in a director it's been
around long enough has a really amazing
understanding of dramas and the
structure of it dramaturgy and comedy
and he's also has an extraordinary and
compassionate understanding of people
and that's all we're in the business of
and the humanity you know he just gets
people and against the way they work and
the way they want and the way they
tripped themselves up on the weight of
the things that they want and you know
that's that's really the the the grip in
the oyster that makes the pearl is you
know to be a really great artist and in
film or in creating you have to be
curious about people and Joss is one of
the most sensitive
and wise people are like when you're
working with Avenue directive on Thor -
or Thor the dark world you got Sir Alan
Taylor who's Gareth thrones director
what was it like working with him what
did he bring to the sequel and are you a
fan of Game of Thrones I am fan of Game
of Thrones I have to say I'm not I'm not
very good at keeping up to speed so
Reese I haven't seen all of the reason
you know the recent series I know
there's been a big who are about certain
plot developments but you know Alan is
amazing he has this extraordinary
breadth of vision really about about the
world of the dark world just the scale
of it what he imagined Asgard to be what
the depth of and and the specificity of
his imagination about
extending the the reach of the film and
taking the audience into into parts of
the Thor universe that they haven't seen
yet and I found that really exciting
what do you think it is about
Shakespeare that works so well on the
big screen
honestly I think it's just Shakespeare's
amazing understanding of humanity he you
know all you have to do really is try
and align yourself with his perspective
on being alive if you know the two crazy
things that we do and and we fall in
love and we fall out of love and we get
in our own way and we get jealous and me
get proud and and with honey and we're
tragic and you know and Shakespeare's
just got the most kind of forensic and
compassionate angle on there the camera
can be very intimate with an actor's
face so there's more opportunity to play
against the text or to play alongside it
so you can you know you can you can play
with the possibility of subtext you know
the flick of an eye the curl of a lip
can say as much as a line but but
actually it's all in it's all in the
text Shakespeare had it down so
as long as you speak it hardly says
speak the speech trippingly on the
tongue don't saw the air you know he
gave him in there's the first player or
the hamlet speech to the players in
Hamlet is the best sort of paragraph of
acting notes you could possibly hope for
funny you mentioned Hamlet there cuz
Joss I said that's the one he'd like to
do next what would he feel if he came
and asked you to do that and what would
your approach be I'd be honored beyond
measure he'd be amazing I mean my
approach would be to learn the thing
inside out and let it happen I suppose
that's why is an interesting part
actually because the actor playing
Hamlet really has to bring themselves to
the role I think not having played it
yet but it seems to me that it's an
amazingly open role and the actor is
asked to think about fathers and mothers
and revenge and friendship and sex and
mortality and philosophy and all of
those things it's just the most heart
attack poetry around
you